Vor ein paar Tagen tauchte völlig
unerwartet ein brandneues
Stealth-Modell auf OpenRouter und
OpenCode auf. Und im Moment ist die
Nutzung für diese Woche noch komplett
kostenlos. Dieses mysteriöse Modell
heißt SpaceMoney Alpha und niemand
weiß so genau, wer es eigentlich
entwickelt hat. SpaceMoney Alpha ist
ein anonymes Large-Language-Modell mit
blitzschneller Inferenz, starken
Programmierfähigkeiten, nativer
Unterstützung für multimodale
Eingaben, anpassbarem Denkaufwand und
einem riesigen Kontextfenster von 1
Million Token. Das Wichtigste, was man
verstehen muss, ist, dass es sich um
ein Stealth-Modell handelt. Es wird von
einem Drittanbieter entwickelt und
betrieben, der während der
Vorschauphase anonym bleiben möchte.
OpenRouter leitet Anfragen lediglich an
dieses Modell weiter, genau wie
OpenCode. Es ist weder der Entwickler,
noch der Eigentümer oder der Anbieter.
Anfangs dachten wir tatsächlich, dass
SpaceMoney Alpha vielleicht das MiniMax
M 3.1 Flash sein könnte. Einer der
größten Hinweise war der Tokenizer.
SpaceMoney schien denselben
Text-Tokenizer wie die Minimax M3-
Familie zu verwenden, was zu vielen
Spekulationen darüber führte, dass
dies insgeheim ein Minimax-Modell sein
könnte, nämlich das kommende M 3.1
Flash-Modell. Doch diese Theorie lässt
sich offensichtlich nicht mehr halten,
da Minimax das M 3.1 Flash mittlerweile
offiziell veröffentlicht hat. Wir sind
also im Grunde wieder am Anfang. Wir
wissen immer noch nicht, wer SpaceMoney
Alpha erschaffen hat, aber was wir
bisher wissen ist, dass dieses Modell
wahnsinnig schnell ist. Tatsächlich
fühlt sich die
Generierungsgeschwindigkeit sogar noch
schneller an als beim Minimax M 3.1
Flash, einem Modell, das speziell auf
Geschwindigkeit und Effizienz ausgelegt
ist. Und ehrlich gesagt sind die
Fähigkeiten in der Webentwicklung
absolut verrückt, denn SpaceMoney
wurde gegen GPT-6 Astra mit "X-High
Thinking" und exakt demselben Prompt
getestet; die Aufgabe war es, einen
detailreichen japanischen Garten im
Voxel-Stil in 3JS zu erstellen, mit
einer Pagode, winzigen Dorfbewohnern,
einem fliegenden Drachen und
interaktiven Details. Hierbei
benötigte das Space-Bunny-Modell etwa
45 Minuten, um die Aufgabe
abzuschließen. Und man darf nicht
vergessen, dass dies bei dieser
Generation komplett kostenlos ist. Dann
haben wir GPT-6 Astra, das mit etwa 15
Minuten deutlich schneller fertig war,
aber die Generierung kostete 4,24 $.
Als ich in diesen Test ging, erwartete
ich eigentlich, dass Astra den Vorteil
haben würde. Doch überraschenderweise
lieferte Space Bunny ein besseres
Ergebnis, das wesentlich detailreicher
aussieht als das von GPT-6 Astra. Es
achtete deutlich mehr auf die kleineren
Details und hat alles, was ich
angefordert hatte, vollständig
ausprogrammiert. Und irgendwie ist es
aktuell immer noch völlig kostenlos
nutzbar. Wenn du also mit diesem Modell
loslegen möchtest, kannst du das ganz
einfach über OpenRouter sowie OpenCode
tun. Und noch einmal, dies ist etwas,
das derzeit frei zugänglich ist, und
Sie können es mit jedem beliebigen
Coding-Agent verwenden. Eine Sache, die
mir aufgefallen ist, ist die Latenz von
74 Tokens pro Sekunde, bei einer
anfänglichen Latenz von 1,5 Sekunden.
Abgesehen davon ist dies ein ziemlich
ordentliches Modell, das schnell ist
und großartige Ergebnisse liefern kann
. Wir werden dieses Modell nun testen,
um zu sehen, was man damit tatsächlich
machen kann, und es dann mit anderen
Modellen vergleichen. Falls ihr es noch
nicht getan habt, würde es mir
unglaublich viel bedeuten, wenn ihr den
YouTube-Kanal abonnieren würdet.
Stellt auch sicher, dass ihr dieses
Video liked, da es mir wirklich hilft,
täglich Videos zu erstellen. Lassen
Sie uns mit diesem Gedanken direkt in
den heutigen Upload eintauchen. Der
Coding-Agent, den ich verwenden werde,
ist Codium Code in VS Code, und ich
stelle Space Money Alpha auf maximale
Überlegung, um all diese Aufgaben zu
erledigen. Wie ihr sehen könnt,
besteht unsere erste Aufgabe darin,
einen 360-Grad-Produktviewer zu
erstellen. Beginnen wir zunächst mit
dem Frontend-Design. Hier habe ich das
Erstellen eines 360-Grad-Produktviewers
angefordert, und das ist das Ergebnis,
das generiert wurde. Dies ist eine
Produktansicht eines Kopfhörers, bei
der man auf die verschiedenen Merkmale
klicken kann, um eine genauere Ansicht
der jeweiligen Funktion zu erhalten.
Man kann die Farbe ändern, und alles
scheint einwandfrei zu funktionieren.
Was mir besonders gefällt, ist, dass
es tatsächlich das 3 D-Produkt
erstellt hat, woran die meisten anderen
Modelle scheitern. Als Nächstes habe
ich die Erstellung eines
macOS-basierten Browsers angefordert,
was wirklich beeindruckend ist, da es
den Glassmorphism-UI-Stil direkt
integrieren konnte. Es gibt ein
Benachrichtigungscenter und die
Möglichkeit, Einstellungen wie Anzeige
und Ton anzupassen. Es gibt sogar einen
Dark Mode, den man aktivieren kann,
also scheinen viele dieser Funktionen
tatsächlich zu funktionieren. Man kann
sogar das Menü in der oberen Leiste
verwenden, was viele der Funktionen
öffnen kann. Das ist also bereits ein
wirklich gutes Zeichen. Es gibt hier
viele verschiedene Apps, die mit
SVG-Icons programmiert wurden, und das
ist etwas, das bei den meisten Modellen
normalerweise nicht programmiert wird.
Nun gibt es ein paar Fehler, wie etwa
wenn ich auf Dinge klicke, dann
flackern alle verschiedenen Browser
oder Anwendungen, aber ansonsten hat es
gute Arbeit geleistet, was für sich
genommen eine wirklich schöne
Darstellung ist. Dies ist etwas, für
das ich etwa 45 Minuten gebraucht habe,
um ein Ergebnis zu erhalten. Es hat
also wirklich lange gedauert, bis
dieses Ergebnis vorlag, und ich
benötigte etwa vier Anläufe für
diese Generierung, aber hier habe ich
die Nvidia-Landingpage für eine
Grafikkarte erstellt. Und ich liebe das
Ergebnis hier einfach. Es hat dieses 3
D-Design einer GPU vollständig
programmiert, was den meisten Modellen
normalerweise nicht gelingt. Man hat
die sich drehenden Lüfter, und es war
in der Lage, alles vom SVG-Logo bis hin
zu all diesen verschiedenen Elementen
von der Typografie bis zur dynamischen
Bewegung, die dieser Landingpage
zugeschrieben wird, zu programmieren.
Insgesamt hat es also wirklich gute
Arbeit bei dieser Generierung geleistet
, und das hatte ich von diesem Modell
wirklich nicht erwartet. Als Nächstes
habe ich es gebeten, einen
Call-of-Duty-Klon zu erstellen, und das
sieht ehrlich gesagt etwas seltsam aus,
da es versucht hat, 3.js für die
Ausgabe zu verwenden, aber daran
gescheitert ist, da es den Code nicht
gründlich genug umgesetzt hat. Es hat
lediglich 2 D-Assets in einer 3
D-Umgebung verwendet, um diese Ausgabe
zu erhalten, weshalb man diese
dynamische Ansicht bekommt, wenn man
über verschiedene Bereiche fährt, und
deshalb sehen die Gegner auch ein wenig
seltsam aus. Ich sage also nicht, dass
es schrecklich ist, aber um diese Art
von Ausgabe zu erhalten, dachte ich, es
wäre viel besser darin, einen 3 D-Klon
von Call of Duty zu generieren,
während es hier eine 3 D-Umgebung
erstellt hat, aber eben mit 2 D-Assets
darin. Wenn du die besten KI-Tools,
Workflows und Neuerscheinungen vor
allen anderen haben möchtest,
abonniere meinen kostenlosen Newsletter
über den Link in der Beschreibung
unten, der komplett kostenlos ist. Eine
weitere 3 D-Generierung, bei der die
Erstellung eines Globus angefragt wurde
, und das Detail hier ist beim
Space-Bunny-Modell wirklich
bemerkenswert. Wenn man es mit der GPT-
6 Soul vergleicht, hat die GPT-6 Soul
etwa 5 Minuten gebraucht und rund
520.000 Token verbraucht, um diese Art
von Ausgabe zu erzielen, was insgesamt
ziemlich gut ist. Als das Space
Money-Modell diesen Globus erstellte,
brauchte es etwa 43 Minuten, was
irgendwie absurd ist. Es dauert zwar
lange, bis dieses Ergebnis vorliegt,
aber wenn man es auf die höchste
Reasoning-Stufe stellt, erhält man
eine bessere Qualität, muss aber
natürlich auch länger auf die Antwort
warten. Es hat tatsächlich etwa
219.000 Token verbraucht, um dieses
Ergebnis zu erzielen, was deutlich
weniger ist als das, was GPT-6
benötigt hat. Natürlich war GPT-6
Soul bei der Erstellung des Ergebnisses
schneller, während Space Money fast
eine Stunde brauchte, um diese Art von
Ergebnis zu generieren. Ich sage nicht,
dass es schlecht ist, aber bei der
Geschwindigkeit braucht das Modell
manchmal länger, wenn man es auf die
höchste Reasoning-Stufe einstellt.
Während Space Money bei normaler
Nutzung schnell ist, ändert sich das
offensichtlich, sobald man den
Reasoning-Aufwand erhöht, was wir
bisher bei vielen dieser Demos gesehen
haben. Aber dieser nächste Test zeigt
uns wirklich, wozu das Modell fähig
ist, wenn man ihm einen detaillierten
Prompt gibt. Hier erhielt Space Bunny
Alpha einen Videoclip eines Spiels und
wurde aufgefordert, es nachzubauen, und
konnte es in HTML ausgeben. Es hat sich
den Clip angesehen, verstanden, was
passiert, und das gesamte Spiel von
Grund auf neu aufgebaut, was einer
seiner Vorteile ist, da dies eine der
Fähigkeiten des Modells bei
multimodalen Eingaben ist. Hierbei hat
es den Sturmeffekt, die Schiffe im
Kugelschreiber-Skizzenstil sowie einen
Boss namens Black Pharaoh nachgebildet.
Das hat es tatsächlich direkt aus dem
HUD des Spiels gelesen, das
Combo-System, Bomben sowie einen
Gewinnbildschirm, und sogar Sounds mit
Web-Audio generiert. Bei maximaler
Reasoning-Einstellung kam das erste
Token nach etwa 7,8 Sekunden, und das
Modell generierte letztlich massive
50.000 Token mit etwa 120 Token pro
Sekunde. Auch wenn das maximale
Reasoning bei größeren
Coding-Aufgaben insgesamt mehr Zeit in
Anspruch nimmt, ist der tatsächliche
Generierungsdurchsatz immer noch
unglaublich schnell. Und denken Sie
daran, es ging nicht darum, irgendein
beliebiges Spiel aus einem Text-Prompt
zu generieren. SpaceHoney hat sich
buchstäblich das Originalspiel
angesehen und versucht, das gesamte
Ding aus dem Video nachzubilden. Oben
sieht man den ursprünglichen Clip, der
vorgegeben wurde, und unten die
Nachbildung von SpaceHoney, die
tatsächlich gerade gespielt wird. Und
wie ich schon sagte, scheint dieser
Checkpoint mit der Zeit immer besser zu
werden. SpaceHoney hat gerade ein
weiteres Update erhalten und ist
irgendwie bereits schneller und
deutlich besser als bei seinem ersten
Erscheinen vor wenigen Tagen. Es sieht
so aus, als ob das Team das Feedback
aus diesen Stealth-Tests nutzt und den
Checkpoint kontinuierlich verbessert.
In diesem Test erhielt Space Money das
Bild eines kompletten Hausplans,
verband es mit Blender und wurde
gebeten, das gesamte Apartment in 3D
nachzubauen. Und etwa eine Stunde
später kam es mit diesem Ergebnis
zurück. Schauen Sie sich nur den
Detailgrad hier an. Es hat den
Grundriss tatsächlich verstanden und
in ein vollständiges 3 D-Apartment
verwandelt. Wenn Ihnen dieses Video
gefällt und Sie den Kanal
unterstützen möchten, können Sie
über die „Super Thanks“-Option
unter dem Video eine Spende tätigen.
Oder Sie treten unserem privaten
Discord bei, wo Sie monatlich
kostenlosen Zugriff auf zahlreiche
Abonnements verschiedener KI-Tools
sowie tägliche KI-News, exklusive
Inhalte und vieles mehr erhalten. Hier
ist ein weiteres Beispiel für das, was
Space Money leisten kann, und da dies
komplett kostenlos geschieht, ist es
wirklich bemerkenswert. Denn jemand gab
ihm einen einzigen Prompt, um eine
vollständige Aktienanalyse-App unter
Verwendung von Open Code und Max
Reasoning zu erstellen. Mit nur einer
Eingabe rief SpaceMoney Marktdaten ab,
erstellte Diagramme, identifizierte
Wettbewerber, zog SEC-Berichte sowie
aktuelle Ereignisse heran und verpackte
alles in eine saubere, responsive
Benutzeroberfläche, die Sie hier sehen
. Sie können im Grunde nach jedem
Unternehmen oder Ticker suchen und
erhalten dessen Aktienperformance,
Finanzdaten, Wettbewerber, Berichte,
Hauptrisiken und sogar Bull-, Base-und
Bear-Szenarien. Das Beeindruckende ist,
dass es vieles davon eigenständig
herausgefunden hat, von der Datenquelle
bis hin dazu, welche Wettbewerber
einbezogen werden sollten. Und noch
einmal: Dieses Modell hat all das
völlig kostenlos erledigt. Auch wenn
es vielleicht länger gedauert hat,
dieses Ergebnis zu erzielen, konnte es
all dies kostenlos leisten, was einfach
bemerkenswert ist. Hier wurde es
gebeten, ein Frontend mit 3 D-Paketen
zu erstellen, und ich muss sagen, das
ist ein ziemlich schönes Frontend, das
es da ausgegeben hat. Man sieht das an
der Typografie und dem
unterschiedlichen Designgeschmack, den
es dieser gesamten Landingpage
verliehen hat, und ich liebe die
Qualität, die es bei diesem speziellen
Output erreicht hat. Nach allem, was
ich bisher getestet habe, ist Space
Funny Alpha insgesamt eines der
interessantesten Stealth-Modelle, die
wir je auf diesem Kanal gesehen haben.
Es ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich
interessant zu sehen, was daraus
letztendlich werden wird. Wir haben
absolut keine Ahnung, wer
dahintersteckt. Aber du kannst jetzt
sofort kostenlos über Open Code und
Open Router darauf zugreifen. Ich werde
die entsprechenden Links unten in die
Beschreibung setzen. Im normalen Modus
ist es schnell, aber wenn man es auf
Maximum stellt, dauert die Ausgabe
etwas länger. Es verfügt über ein
riesiges Kontextfenster. Es bietet alle
Modalitäten, was wirklich großartig
ist. Insgesamt ist es ein wirklich
tolles Modell, das dir beeindruckende
Ergebnisse liefern wird, besonders bei
der Webentwicklung. Und da es kostenlos
ist, solltest du das Beste daraus
machen. Damit hoffe ich, Leute, dass
euch das heutige Video gefallen hat und
ihr etwas mitnehmen konntet. Lasst mich
wissen, was ihr glaubt, was Space
Monkey Alpha ist. Schaut euch unbedingt
die School-Community an, werft einen
Blick auf die World of AI by Coin
Alpha-Plattform, besucht unseren
zweiten Kanal, abonniert den Newsletter
, tretet dem Discord bei, folgt mir auf
Twitter und stellt zu guter Letzt
sicher, dass ihr den Kanal abonniert,
die Glocke aktiviert, dieses Video
liked und unsere früheren Videos
anseht, um bei den neuesten
KI-Nachrichten auf dem Laufenden zu
bleiben. Mit diesen Gedanken wünsche
ich euch einen fantastischen Tag.
Verbreitet Positivität, und wir sehen
uns in Kürze wieder. Macht's gut,
Leute.